Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricard Lops, and
today I'm joined for a 5th time by Doctor
Kevin Mitchell. He's associate professor of Genetics and neuroscience
at Trinity College, Dublin. And today we're going to
talk about individual differences in psychological traits, how we
can study them, how we should interpret them, and
also a little bit about group differences. So Kevin,
welcome back on the show. You're already a regular,
so yeah,
thanks Ricardo. It's great to be back. Thanks a
lot.
OK, so, um, let me start by asking you
this. Of course, some of the things we're going
to talk about today, we've already at least touched
on them, perhaps not into the level of detail
that we're going to talk about them today when
in our first interview about your book in Nate,
but Um, what are individual differences in psychological traits?
I mean, what are people talking about psychologists, neuroscientists,
cognitive scientists when we refer to that? Yeah,
I think, I mean, I think we can just
start with like what are we all talking about
when we describe people in different ways. We're just
recognizing that they have some stable patterns of behaving,
um. That apply or are manifested across contexts, right?
So, the idea is just, you know, the fact,
I mean, English, for example, has 8000 words for
what we could call personality traits, you know, shy,
outgoing, lively, stubborn, conscientious, open-minded, what, you know, we've
got so many, so many words for these things.
And, and What they're tracking is that when we
see someone else's behavior or our own, um, we
notice certain patterns. So if we say someone's shy,
that means that that over many different kinds of
circumstances and scenarios, they're behaving in a way where
we think, OK, there's something stable about the person
themselves. It's not just the situation that they're in.
It's that it's that person in the situation that
produces the behavior, right? And so it's just a
recognition that between all of us. We have these
dispositions or I, I like to think of them
as sort of tunings of, of underlying parameters of
decision making that influence um what we do in
any given situation without like, they're not controlling what
we do because they don't have any information about
anything, right? They're, they're information free in, in, in
the sense that they're not about anything out in
the world. They're just a tuning of this individual
parameter, like, you know, how risk averse you are.
It could be just something that's sort of stable
between people. And that makes sense because we know
that's stably different between species, right? Some species are
very risk averse and very skittish, um, others are,
um, you know, braver in a sense, right? Um,
SO the idea that there can be biological differences
in those parameters isn't, um, anything, it's not saying
anything, you know, controversial. It's basically saying, look, humans
have some human nature generally, but we all have
variations on that nature and Those are the things
that we call these, the psychological personality words, right?
Um, THE question then is like how do you
study them and how do you put some, you
can't go around studying 8000, uh, dimensions of, of
personality between. Between your subjects
also because, also because some of those words might
be used as synonyms.
Yeah, well, that's exactly the thing is that many
of those words are synonyms. So, you know, if
you say that someone is shy or withdrawn or
um well there's a bunch of other words uh
for that, then. All of those things are clearly
tapping into the same underlying idea, right? The same
underlying parameters. And so what people did actually in
personality psychology was, was cluster analysis. So they took
all those words and they, and they saw which
ones of them are really just um synonyms or
are in some way related to each other or
correlated with each other. And that was the way
that they tried to actually boil down those, you
know, 8000. Different terms into some set of dimensions
where they could say actually underlying all of this
stuff, there's variation along these two major dimensions or
5 or 6 or 16, uh, you know, there's
a bunch of different um schemes that people have
come up with for major dimensions of personality difference.
Yeah, uh, but by the way, when it comes
to how we uncover scientifically those personality traits, um,
when you say that, for example, in English, people
have around 8000 words to refer to personality traits,
I mean, So, uh, the uh, the way that
people come, came up with, for example, the big
five personality traits, and I have back in 2018,
Doctor Louis Goldberg, who was one of the main
people behind that. Uh, HE'S unfortunately already passed earlier
this year, but, um, yeah, of course, he applied
the lexical hypothesis, which is doing exactly what you
described. There in terms of cluster analysis and all
of that, but, uh, when people arrive at, uh,
the big five or the exao or other ways
of, uh, grouping different traits that people might vary
on, uh, is that supposed to ever be an
exhaustive list or is just simply what comes up
when people, uh, cluster. Those traits in particular statistical
ways.
Yeah, uh, more of the latter, I think. I
don't think anybody would claim that they're, that those
things are, are exhaustive, either that they exhaust all
the dimensions of variation, or that if you know,
you know, someone's scores on those, say, the big
five or hexao or something, that you have like
total predictive power over what they're going to do,
right? They're, so they're very much partial, um. Statistical
constructs that capture some trends about the ways that
people behave. And, you know, one way to think
about that is to is to actually Ask people
how they, how they tend to behave in different
scenarios and then look at, look at the answers
to these various questions. I mean this is basically
how personality scores are generated, right? You're just literally
asking people how do you behave, but um. You
know, you could ask people like, do you like
to travel, uh, do you like to socialize? Do
you like to, uh, do you like to have
sex? Like how much do you like to have
sex, those kinds of things, and you would think,
um, that maybe those things would be independent of
each other, but they're not, they're correlated with each
other. So people who, who like to travel also
tend to like to socialize, right. And so then
you can do some statistics and basically there's sort
of a couple ways of looking at that. One
could be like that those different pairs all have
some correlations between them because they share some common
causation. And the other would be is like if
you see a bunch of those that have those
correlations that may be underlying all of them is
one shared construct. There's one shared thing which in
this case we would call extraversion. And when you
do that, like it gives you a statistical construct,
this latent construct, which is contributing to something of
the variation in all those um behaviors, but it
doesn't explain it fully, right? So extraversion contributes something
to how much you'd like to travel, statistically speaking,
but there's also a little bit of extra variation
left over, right? So for me, one of the
interesting um questions is what do those constructs represent
ontologically? Like you can say it's a statistical measure
and it's a way of modeling things, that's great.
But does it actually point to a singular thing
like in the brain that's, that, that can be
tuned up or down, which is the extraversion dial,
right? Or is there an extraversion circuit in the
brain that is just fires more in some people
versus others. Or is it still quite diverse uh
set of underlying parameters that all, you know, can
contribute to this domain of, of behaving that we
recognize as more or less extroverted where it's a
little bit of us imposing, um, trying to impose
order on something that's quite messy and in doing
that reifying the construct. By thinking I've imposed order
with this statistical construct, therefore that's a thing, and
the reason I'm saying this is that you people
have looked in the brain, right? They've looked in
the brain for circuits that vary with how extroverted
somebody is or conscientious or any of these other
traits. And they very consistently failed to find anything.
Basically, there aren't any brain markers of those personality
traits.
Uh, CAN I just ask you, when you refer
to ontology, are you alluding in any way to
that distinction that some cognitive scientists and philosophers of
cognitive science make between substance ontology and process ontology
in the sense of thinking about personality traits as
being sort of fixed or being, or uh or
varying over time in terms of, uh, I don't
know, their. DEGREE, I mean, maybe someone in a
particular context is more extroverted, less extroverted when their
life circumstances change, maybe they are more prone to
depression, less prone to depression, or more or less
neurotic.
Yeah, I, I wasn't referring to that, but those
are all really important points. I was referring more
generally to the idea of ontology as the, you
know, the study of what is, what exists, and
the idea that when we When we generate a
statistical measure like an extroversion score or a neuroticism
score that we then infer that extraversion, that is
a thing like that exists in in the brain
somewhere. Um, BUT you're, you know, you make the
wider point here that's really important, which, which is
that, um, people's personality traits are just these underlying
dispositions and. Their actual behavior in the world, first
of all is going to be dependent on the
situation that they find themselves in as the person
that they are in that situation, um, and of
course, you know, people's actual, you know, patterns of
behavior can change if they've had, I mean, grief
is a is a good example where, you know,
if you've lost a loved one. Um, IT may
be for a long time afterwards, uh, you might
not be as extroverted as you were before, right?
You know, that's, that's a very typical kind of
a thing. Um, BUT the other aspect of that
is that, that I find really interesting is that,
um, The way that we behave in any moment
is a reflection not just of these underlying dispositions
and the current situation, but of everything we've learned
along the way, right? It's this very constructive process,
and that's where the process ontology thing, I think,
becomes interesting because I would see our character. As
a reflection of these underlying dispositions and all of
the experiences that we've had through our lives and
all of the choices that we've made and all
of the ways that we've built up our, our
habits and our policies and our knowledge of the
world and just constructed our identity basically through our
actions, through our lives, um, which is a, you
know, it's a much more agential way of looking
at, um, How we come to be the person
that we are and how we express that identity
in our behavior in the world.
Mhm. Yes, uh, uh, I mean, uh, I, I,
I asked you that because since around 2023, I've
been having talks with people who do work in,
uh, dynamical systems theory, for example, I mean people
like uh Inezi Palitu and uh Naomi Reuter. And
I mean, everyone that, uh, basically learns cognitive science
in the Netherlands is a very interesting, uh, subject
because they actually learn dynamical systems theory that is
non-representationalist, non-computationalist approaches to cognitive science. And psychology which
is very different from what we have, for example,
as a bases here in Portugal, I, I would
imagine also in Ireland so because that, that really
brings a completely new way of approaching and understanding
uh. A personality traits and psychological traits more broadly
as not really something that we are predisposed to
and so it's fixed in time and space, but
it's something that is always in a dynamical relationship
with, uh, I don't know, the rest of our
body, our environment, our culture, and so on.
Yeah, no, I absolutely think that that's right and
the um. So if you're trying to understand anyone's
actual behavior in the world, right, you have to
think of all those things. You have to think
of their history, you have to think of their,
their motivations, their current states, what they know, what
they think they know, um, what situation the world
is presenting, what their goals are, um, and their
dispositions. And their dispositions, I would draw a distinction
with their predispositions, right? I mean, I, I would
say we're born with some predispositions. That doesn't mean
Those are our dispositions at every moment of, of
our lives, right? The dispositions are a little bit
more fluctuating, can change over time, can change dynamically,
um, within short time frames, but, you know, underpinning
that, there may still be some of these predispositions
that are more stable tunings, right? But it's just
that they don't, they don't control us in every
moment. And I think, you know, the dynamical systems
view for me is just the right way of
thinking about biology, generally speaking. Like if you're missing,
if you're missing the dynamics, you're missing the liveliness
of life, the interactiveness of life, um, and the
situatedness of any organism in its environment. And those,
those dialectics are what life is, right? Is that
those relations are, um, How life expresses itself. And
actually for me, you know, the dynamical systems theory
is, is really key, um, control theory and cybernetics,
I think are really interesting too, especially when you're
talking about personality where, you know, You could say,
so I, I said I, I, I give, you
know, lectures on personality and genetics, but I set
my students a little challenge at the start of
it. I say, OK, so you have to design
a robot, it has to get around in the
world. Um, WHAT are you gonna equip it with,
right? And they quickly get to the idea of,
well, it, it needs some sensors, uh, it needs
some motors, and then, uh, maybe it needs to
monitor its own internal states. Maybe it's, you know,
it's, it's low on fuel or whatever, but it
maybe there's a few internal. States where it might
have to make a choice between certain things like
here, yeah, I need fuel, but there's danger or
there's a, an attractive robot mate potential over there,
whatever it is, right? Um, AND then, you know,
they, they, they sort of come to the idea,
well, maybe then it needs a control system to
adjudicate between these different things in any scenario, um,
to say, OK, uh, I'm gonna weight these things
a certain way and make a choice between a
possible threat and, and an opportunity. But the next
step is to realize that I, like, you need
to tell it what the relative weights should be
or it needs to learn. Um, AND I might
tune my robot with a slightly different weights to
yours. Like I might tune my, my novelty seeking
dial a little higher and my risk aversion dial
a little lower, and, you know, whatever my reward
sensitivity a little higher. And, and so, once you
think about those, you realize like there's no right
answer. To that. There's no set of tunings that's
going to be the best for every scenario, and
that I think reflects, you know, the diversity across
human beings and actually not just human beings, like
every animal species has something we could call personality,
some variation on the species typical nature. And so
if you think about that in In control system
terms, it's like, yeah, I'm I'm gonna need some
underlying um parameters that feed into this control system
that are going to allow me to um determine
my own behavior and govern my own behavior in
over complex scenarios and multiple time frames and so
on.
No, it's interesting that you also referred to, to
other animal models because uh in my conversations with
primatologists on the show, uh, I actually got to
learn that even when thinking about, so let's say
we're talking about chimpanzees. There were, I remember perfectly
well that there was this one interview where I
asked the primatologist, so, Um, in terms of hierarchy,
how do chimpanzee societies function, and the way he
answered was like, OK, what chimpanzee society are you
referring to? Are you referring to chimpanzee societies in
Gombe and then he mentioned other sites because The
ecological circumstances vary, the way that they structure their
societies also varies. So I mean, even when it
comes to other animals and until at least very
recently, and unfortunately some people still use those terms,
terms like Um, instinct, I mean, I guess that
fixed action pattern is more, uh, rigorous scientifically, but
even when people think about something that is part
of the evolved behavioral repertoire of a particular species,
they think that it's just a fixed and that.
Particular individuals of a particular species, regardless of the
ecological circumstances they inhabit, they will respond exactly the
same way to similar stimuli, but that's just not
the case. It's
not, and, and I think two things can be
true, right? There can be a species typical nature.
Maybe this is gonna be 3 things. Um, THERE
can be, in fact, there, there, there must be
variation around that nature in the same way that
there must be variation around the physical nature of
any species, right? All these chimps don't look the
same. Uh, BECAUSE there's genetic variation that affects how
bits of their bodies grow. Well, there's genetic variation
that affects how bits of their brain grow as
well, and, and it's basically inescapable. There's no way
that there couldn't be some variation around that. So
if there's any sense in which the nature of
a species is encoded in its genome in the
and in the broadest terms, then we have to
expect that there should be individual variation around that.
But at the same time, We also have to
have to realize that there's this embeddedness of the
species in a context and that is where these
underlying this underlying nature will be expressed. And so,
you know, the challenge for People studying personality is,
you know, to not just throw their hands up
in the air and say, look, this is all
too complex. It's always context dependent. Um, I can't
get a grip on anything, right? And so what
they're doing, what they're trying to do is literally
just get rid of the context or look for
patterns that apply across context in a statistical sense.
And I think sometimes what people think they're trying
to do. Is explain every bit of every behavior
all the time, and they're not, right? They're they're
just abstracting away from the context dependence and all
of the details of any given situation to see
are there underlying patterns of variation, and the answer
is there are, and those can be studied without
it, without anyone involved in that enterprise claiming that
they explain everything about behavior all the time.
So, uh, let's talk a little bit about how
we study genetic predispositions and of course there can
be other disciplines and other scientific tools, but, uh,
talking first about behavioral genetics and the gold standard
in behavioral genetics tends to be. Uh, THE study
of, uh, twins reared apart, monozygotic twins, zygotic twins,
and sometimes people also study, uh, adoptees, uh, and
then, of course, compare, uh, twins, um. Monozygotic dizygotic
twins and uh adoptees, but what can we learn
about genetic predisposition from behavioral genetics? I mean, uh,
what do you think are its limitations maybe?
Yeah, um, well, there's lots of limitations. Um, LET
me start, I guess, with the, with the basic
observation is that you have some trait that varies
across the population. So if I measure extroversion, I
give people these questionnaires, um, I'll see some people
are high on extroversion and some people are low.
And I have a, I have a kind of
a pseudo quantitative score that I'm giving people, right?
Which is just a, it's just a statistical proxy
for something that we recognize in our real lives,
um, day to day anyway, right? OK, so I've
got variation across, uh, across the population. And like
any, like most traits, um, that's going to be
a normal distribution, right? There's gonna be a lot
of people who are sort of in the middle,
and you've got some really, really shy people and
some really, really outgoing people at the extremes. And
then the, the question is, what causes that variation?
What are the sources of variation in that trait?
And of course, the, the, the sort of the
age old idea that, well, maybe you were just
born that way because of your genetics, or maybe
you are that way because you were raised that
way. So the classic nature versus nurture dichotomy. And
one way to tease that apart, I mean, the
problem is you can't just look at at similarities
between relatives and answer the question, right? If you
see that relatives are more similar to each other
than non-relatives, which is true. Then you don't know
the answer to the question whether it was nature
or nurture, and that's where twin studies, family studies,
um, adoption studies, and so on have been so
useful, but they are absolutely limited in lots of
ways. But the basic idea is that You can
tease out the contributions to the variance in a
trait. Without um saying that you can disentangle the
causal contributions to to an individual person's the way
that they actually are, right? So you can't for
me disentangle the effects of genes and environment or
experience in the way that I am right now,
but you can across a population say how much
does variation in genes contribute to variation in the
trait, and it's a, it's a different thing. Um,
AND I, it's really important to, to emphasize that
what behavioral genetics is interested in is explaining differences
and, and variants, not explaining everything about the way
that somebody is or, or, you know, everything about
their phenotype in a productive way. It's a, it's
a difference making kind of causation that we're after.
So when you do that, you can do these
various designs and say, OK, look, if it was
nurture that was making people the way that they
are, then anyone raised in the same family should
be more similar to each other. And when you
look for personality traits and you look at adoptive
siblings. They're almost not, no more like each other
than any two strangers on the street. Like it
really just that observation by itself suggests that being
raised in the same family does not in fact
make you more similar to each other. And actually,
I mean, I should, what I've done here is
I've gone from talking about variation across the population
to similarity, which is the flip side, right? So
what we're doing whenever we're doing behavioral genetics is
actually studying similarity between people and what makes people
more similar to each other, but it's, it's, it's
the inverse of a source of variation, right? So
you can also look at twins who are reared
apart and like you said, this is the the
the sort of gold standard is you take identical
twins, monozygotic twins who share the same genome, but
who've been adopted separately and raised separately in different
families, and then you can ask, well, Uh, you
know, a family environment is important in generally in
making them similar to each other when they're raised
in the same family, then they should be less
similar to each other when they're raised in different
families, and the answer is they're not, they're not
much less similar actually, they're quite still quite similar
now. You know, some of the limitations of those
particular experiments is just the numbers, right? It's hard
to find twins, monozygotic twins who are reared apart.
That's not the the
sample the sample is usually low,
right? Yeah, it's low and it's usually reflects some
particular. Um, HISTORICAL circumstances, sometimes, I mean, you know,
after the Second World War, for example, the number
of children had to be, you know, were adopted
and, and, you know, shipped off to different families
and so on, but thankfully that's a rare, um,
kind of condition. So when those when we do
those studies, those are a couple of the designs,
the adoptive designs, you know, twins reared apart, um.
Sorry, I should have, I should have said that
actually all of this, what we're using or what
we're interested in is the correlation in the phenotype
between pairs of, of individuals who have different degrees
of relatedness or who have been reared in the
same family or not. And by doing that you
can dissociate these different sources of, of variation. Um,
AND the other kind of classic design is to
take identical twins who are obviously born at the
same time and reared in the same family, and
then see, well, how similar are many, many pairs
of identical twins versus um fraternal twins, right? So
dizygotic twins who, who are basically just like siblings,
right? They share 50% of their genes. But who
are also born at the same time and raised
in the same family, so you would say, OK,
this is as close as we can get to
an ideal control comparison. And then, um, you know,
the idea is if the monozygotic twins are much
more similar to each other than the dizygotic twins,
that shows really a genetic influence. So you can
do all those kinds of studies and then um
you can put some numbers on this and say,
here's how much of the variance that we see
in this trait across the population that we can
attribute to genetic differences versus something else. And the
bit, the proportion that you can contribute to genetic
differences is what we call the heritability. And there's
a whole bunch of, of kind of mathematical assumptions
that go into actually generating a number. Um, MY
own feeling is that the exact number doesn't really
matter. It's not like a biological constant. Um, YOU
might find that, you know, extroversion in your population
is 40% heritable, and that means 40% of the
variants that we see across the whole population is
attributable to genetic differences, which means the rest is
something else. But it could be, you know, in
your study, it might be 40%, in my study,
it might be 50% or 30%. It doesn't really
matter. I tend to think of them as in
sort of in buckets of like low, moderate, high.
Mm, yeah, you know, it's funny because er in
Portuguese the common words that we use to refer
to monozygotic and dizygotic twins is true twins and
false twins, so I mean the dizygotic is, it's
like, oh they're not really twins, they're like just
normal siblings.
They're just like normal siblings who happen to share
a womb, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, uh, let me ask you
about heritability because this, I think that this is
a concept that many people have misconceptions about and
I, I, I, it's, it's not for, uh, it's
for good reasons because I, I mean it's. The
concept that it's really hard to grasp for most
people, but what does it mean, for example, for
a trait to be 70% heritable? I mean, does
that mean that it is 70% genetic?
It means that again, heritability just applies to variance,
and variance is. It's something that most people are
not, don't, don't think about as a mathematical defined
thing, right? But you can measure the variance of
something across the population, which is just, you know,
you say, take the height of people and you
can say, well, um, the variance in height across
the whole population is this much and it's a
number, right? Um, WHEREAS if you take a height
of just NBA basketball players, the variance in height
is going to be less, right? Cause you've just
sampled this bit of the population, so the bell
curve is going to be narrower. And if you
took just monozygotic twins, it would be really narrow
for height, right? There would be very little variance
left. And that kind of gives this intuition, right?
So we have the whole population, here's the, here's
the spread of values of, of height. Now, imagine
everybody was a clone. Uh, LIKE the, not just
pairs of twins, but everybody was genetically identical, then
the distribution would be like, come, you know, very
narrow. So, um. In a sense, the heritability reflects
how much narrower the distribution would be if everybody
was genetically identical. THAT makes sense. I haven't said
it that way out loud before, but that in
my mind that that's a sort of an intuitive
way to, to think about it is like, OK,
because we're genetically different from each other, because we're
not clones, then the distribution of this trait spreads
out. And that's true for physical traits and it's
true for um cognitive behavioral traits like personality measures
and so on. So if something is 70% heritable,
that means that 70% of the variants. In the
trade that you see the spread of values in
the trade that you see in the population that
you're studying. Is attributable to genetic differences in the
population that you're studying. Right and It doesn't mean
that 70% of a person's extroversion comes from their
genes and the other 30% from something else, right?
That's not, it just, it doesn't apply to an
individual. It just applies to a population because it's
about how people vary across the population.
Yeah, but this is really a very common misconception,
right, because it's not that uncommon for, for you
to read even sometimes in, uh, I don't know,
uh, just popular uh publications that sometimes, uh, divulge
a little bit of science, do a little bit
of science communication that, oh, a new twin study
found out. That, uh, I don't know, personality traits
are 50% genetic, and they put it in those
terms, but that's not really the correct way of
thinking about it.
Yeah, yeah, and the problem is like the word
heritable, um, you know, it sounds like, uh, it,
it sounds like a colloquial term, but it's a
super, super technical term, and actually even within that
there's multiple types, there's different. There's narrow sense heritability,
there's broad sense, like it's a very technical term
from quantitative genetics and really, you know, it came
from animal breeding and in animal breeding, like it
matters what the number is, because you might have
a trait in a, in a population of cattle
or something like that. You say you measure milk
yield in a population of cattle, and then you
want to know it's like I've got some here
that are really give really good milk yield, or
if it's bulls, like their daughters give really good
milk yield. Um, HOW much can I increase the
milk yield of the population in the next generation
if I just breed from those, uh, those cows
and bulls at the extreme, right? And, and you
can put a number on that. You can get
over how much is the population going to respond
to selection. And if the trade is highly heritable,
then that means it's worth doing this breeding to
push the population mean. And that's how we have
done, like that's what we've done when we've domesticated
animals and we have pushed them by breeding, um,
and the same for plants. So, There the the
actual value becomes important, like whether it's 4% or
40% is going to predict how much of a
gain you're going to get in the next generation
in this trait that you're interested in. Um, SO
that's a, a different, more operationalized perspective on what
heritability is as a tool that people use, like
a mathematical tool to say, yeah, uh, this much
of the variation in the trait that I see
is due to genetics and therefore I can breed
for that trait, and this is the response that
I, I can expect. Whereas if none of it
was due to genetics, then it wouldn't matter which
individuals you bred from, they'd all, the next generation
would all be the same.
So, uh, still on the topic of heritability, let's
tackle what might be another common misconception. So, uh,
if a trait is highly heritable, what kind of
implications does that have? I mean, does it necessarily
mean that it is less permeable to environmental inputs,
to environmental influences? Does it mean that it is
harder to change or not,
um, not, it doesn't necessarily mean any of those
things. So, again, it's very population specific and you
might find in one, in one population that something
like height is actually very highly heritable, like 80
to 90% heritable. Most of the variation we see
is due to genetic differences. And yet, If you
compare across populations, there's mean differences in average height.
And they actually track with um like protein intake
in the first few years of life. So it's
really infant nutrition. And, and so you can make
sense of those two observations. It seems like they're
conflicting, right? One is saying, look, this is mostly
genetic in origin, the variation, and the other is
like there's clearly an environmental source of variation that
makes a big difference. And you can, you can
reconcile those by, by realizing what it is you
did when you did your study on the heritabilities.
You took one population that just may not have
a lot of environmental variation in it. And then
you ask, given that set of circumstances, what's the
proportion of variation that I see this due to
genetic differences. Now, if you expanded that over many,
many countries and you did the same study at
the same time, then what you would find is
that the heritability would go down. So it's not
a fixed number, it's a proportion. And it can
go down as other sources of variation increase. So
if there's more environmental differences, your heritability will be
lower just by definition. It doesn't mean whatever those
biological influences don't exist anymore. It's just you've added
a bunch of other ones, right? So when we
do, um, you know, twin studies or family studies
and so on, we're almost always just Trying to
control for all that other variation. We're not doing
it worldwide, right? We're doing it in like the
Minnesota twin study or the, you know, the Scotland
twin study or something. They're very local defined populations
and, and so that can give a misleading view
that In a population, just because there isn't a
lot of environmental variation affecting the trait, it can
lead you to infer that environmental variation can't affect
the trait, and that's just not correct. It's a
very much a contingent kind of a measure specific
to the study that you've done. And then the
other, the other question is like, is it um.
Is the eventual trait amenable to any kind of
um non-genetic or environmental factors or or so on,
and there I think the answer varies by trait.
It's not necessarily true that just because something is
50% heritable, that it's also, uh, you know, amenable
to, to variation by any sort of systematic factors
in the environment that may or may not be
true. Um, IN many cases it, it is, I
mean if you think about something like intelligence, um,
like intelligence as the ability to think well is
clearly trainable, right? I mean, that's why we do
education. So the idea that there's just this fixed
biological innate IQ score that is then not um
uh affected by any of your experiences is just
silly in my mind because of, of course it
is, right? That's why we have schooling. So, um,
for personality traits, it's really interesting. I mean, it's
kind of an open question whether in fact there
are any kind of systematic factors that vary in
the environment that are correlated with, say, making people
more neurotic or more extroverted or more conscientious, and
of course people have done loads and loads of
work trying to find those and, you know, one
of the Inferences from um behavioral genetics is that
actually these traits are only partly heritable and that
already leads people to think, well, the rest must
be environmental, right? It must be something outside the
organism. And maybe we can find what those factors
are. And so people have looked for, for any
kind of systematic factors, you know, things like whether
your parents got divorced when you were young, like
does that have a systematic effect on people's personality
traits. So you just take a bunch of people
whose parents did get divorced and a bunch of
people who didn't, and you ask if their scores
on, say, neuroticism are higher or lower. And basically
they've not found anything that's really systematic, there are
just aren't any clear sort of life experiences, maybe
like with the, the exception of really like severe
neglect or abuse, which can obviously have very, very
long lasting deep psychological effects, but um which thankfully
is, is fairly rare and um so in the,
in the more general realm of, of, of experiences
that aren't as extreme as that. There don't seem
to be any good correlations. I mean, birth order
was a is a a famous one that people
have thought, you know, was tied to different personality
traits, and it just, it just isn't. Um, YOU
know, those, those effects have just kind of gone
away as people have done larger and larger studies.
So, yeah, for personality traits, it's interesting that Yeah,
they're only partly heritable. Um, EVEN if they were
fully heritable, that wouldn't mean in principle that they
couldn't be malleable or subject to experience. And yet
when you look at them, in fact, for those
traits, it doesn't seem to be good um evidence
that the, that the really underlying biological disposition, disposition.
Is affected by experience. Of course, how it's how
it's expressed is of course affected by experience, right?
That's how we come to. Adapt ourselves to the
world and accommodate to to experience and so on.
So it's um, yeah, it's subtle because there's different.
There isn't just one simple answer to to the
question, it just varies by different traits, I think.
Uh, WHAT would you say are the most rigorous
scientific ways of studying environmental influences on, uh, personality
traits or other kinds of, uh, psychological traits?
Um, WELL, I should preface this by saying I'm
not like I'm not a personality psychologist and I'm
not a sociologist, right? So, so those, those people
could answer that question better, um, better than I
could. But, you know, a simple design like what
I just talked about is, is just. Looking at
uh groups of people who had exposure to one
type of experience versus another or who've been brought
up in one kind of environment versus another and
seeing if there's systematic differences in, in how they
behave or their scores on personality traits. Um, THERE
may be systematic differences in how they actually behave
without there being differences in their underlying personality traits,
so. You know, the challenge when working with, um,
human beings obviously is that we can't do interventions,
right? We can't do controlled interventions in in the
way that we can do in in animals, um.
So, you know, if we were thinking, you know,
a really rigorous way to do this, if we
accept that animals also have personality differences and in
fact that sometimes the dimensions of their personality differences.
Map onto the dimensions of human personality differences, then,
um, then thinking about, you know, doing work in
animal models is another angle that you can take
in there you can control the environment, you can
control the um The experiences that animals have. Yeah,
Again, um, I think the answer sort of is
kind of the same is that there really are
innate differences between individuals. Um, THOSE underlying differences are
pretty refractory to change, and yet the way that
they're expressed, the thing that we're actually interested in,
is very much subject to experience and um. I
is, is, you know, an expression of the actualities
of the experience of an individual as opposed to
the sort of cloud of potentialities that that we
could think of.
So when it comes to the environment and how
we should think about, uh, I mean, the role
of nature and nurture in shaping our psychology, another
concept coming from behavioral genetics is the concept of
gene-environment correlation, and we have passive gene-environment correlations, active
gene-environment correlations, and reactive gene-environment correlation. So, I mean,
It, uh, what people might think is being environmental
influences might just be, for example, uh, your parents
sharing some of the the same genes with you
and having, uh, similar personality traits or people just,
uh, treating you differently because of your own personality
traits or for example, you because you have a
particular kinds of Interests seek actively seeking environments where
you can fulfill those interests. I don't know if
I love reading, maybe I spend more time at
the library or something like that or have friends
who are also intellectuals or something like that and
that further reinforces my, my personality traits, my interests.
So, but, but I mean, when can. We say,
or, or even do you think that it is
a proper question to ask uh whether we can
tell when a personnel or when a personality or
when the environment changes a trait or when it
reinforces it? I mean, do you think that that's
a proper question to ask or
I think it's a reasonable question to ask, um,
again. You can think about it in terms of
sources of variance, right? And, and what I talked
about earlier was this idea that we can separate
the, the genetic sources of variance from environmental sources.
And of course, that's, that's one of the assumptions
underlying the calculation of an actual number in, in
like twin studies and so on, is that there
isn't any interaction between those two terms, that they're
independent from each other and they're just acting separately.
And of course, it may well be that under,
you know, people could vary. In a way where,
for example, they're vulnerable to some kind of environmental
stressors, where um, in the absence of those stressors,
these people would end up behaving just exactly the
same as each other, but when those stressors appear,
some of those people um will show a phenotype
and and and others won't, and you know this
comes into play with things like um psychiatric. Disorders
or mental, uh, mental illness where, um, I mean,
we saw this during COVID, for example, where, you
know, the circumstances were so brutal during, during lockdown
and so on where people were really isolated, their
support systems were gone, that many people actually developed
mental illness in a way that they would not
have done otherwise. So if you were just, if
you were just drawing back from that and, and
looking at Mental illness as a phenotype and saying,
you know, is there a genetic effect or is
there an environmental effect? Clearly in that case, there's
a, there's an interaction between those two. So with
personality traits, it's perfectly reasonable to suppose that there
might be an interaction between those two things, um,
broadly speaking, but then the question is, how do
you actually study it? It turns out to be
really hard. To study in, uh, in a global
sense because you just, you, you just don't know
how to model it. You almost have to say,
you almost have to put the terms into your
model mathematically in order to get them out. If
you don't put them in, you won't get it,
you won't get them out basically. Or you have
to do very specific experiments. They're not, they're not
global experiments. They're much more local saying, OK, I'm
looking at the interaction between neuroticism as a personality
trait and Um, some kind of life event that,
yeah, like divorce, say your parents got divorced, um,
and then asking, OK, do kids who are more
neurotic, um, you know, have more negative consequences when
their parents get divorced than kids who are not
neurotic, that kind of thing, right? So that's a
much more local design that you can, um, that
you can do, but. You know, more generally, I
think the. You, you also touched on, so here,
when I was talking just then, it, it was
like framing things as experiences as things that have
happened to you, where you're not actively involved in
that, it's just you're, you're passive, and those are
factors from the outside affecting you. And I think
that that's true, those, those can exist, but I
think it's also true that a lot of our
environment and our experiences is crafted by us. Or
initially crafted by our parents who may share uh
genes with us and genetic predispositions as you said,
so, you know, you may have, um, uh, say
a child who's maybe anxious, uh, you know, biologically
speaking. May have parents who are also share that
trait a little bit and they may be a
bit overbearing or overprotective, and then you can get
a kind of an amplification in the, in the
behavior of the, of the individual, or at least
in the relationship between the the child and their
parents that reflects that, right? Um, YOU talk about
and the, and the thing when it comes to
that example, the thing is that when people see
a situation like that, they might immediately assume that
the child is anxious because the parents are creating
an anxious environment, but it's, it might just be
that they share some of the same, the same
genes that predispose to anxiety. Yeah,
exactly, or there's the other factor that you suggested,
which is that um. Some of the behavior of
the parents is actually evoked by the personality of
the child, right? Children have different personalities, and you
like to think as a parent it's like, oh,
I'm treating everybody exactly the same, and it's like,
like hell you are. You're in a relationship with
this child and you're reacting, you know, as much
as anything else. So, so there's that sense in
which the child can evoke, um, some patterns of
behavior in their parents or. Siblings or friends or
peers or teachers that then can feed back onto
their um Onto their own development and you know,
the most obvious kind of case of that is
a child who is very disruptive for whatever underlying
reason. Um, Can can engender negative interactions or interactions
that other people perceive negatively that then can feed
back onto a pattern of, of disruption, right? Um,
SO what, you know, at early stages we've got
those two things going on. You've got, you know,
there you are as a baby, you're not really
in control of anything, but you're in an environment,
at least if you're biologically related to your parents,
that, um, Some of your underlying genetics may be
expressed through them and the environment that they create.
Which is, that's a challenge in itself when you
look at heritability because actually heritability of something like
intelligence actually partly reflects the fact that some of
the genes that you're carrying are shared by your
parents and they're creating an environment which influences your
intellectual development. So there's those complexities are all um
can be all kind of woven together. But then
like as as individuals get older, they're not just
evoking reactions, they're actually creating their own experiences. They're
seeking experiences, they're creating environments, they're choosing who to
hang out with, they're following their, their interests in,
in what they're doing. Like you said with reading,
you know, if you look at how well people
read, that's a factor of both potentially, you know,
some underlying um aspect of cognitive ability. Generally, maybe
some ability that's more particular to reading, but then
also just practice, right? I mean, that's just a
skill that people learn and they're not going to
learn it if they don't practice it. And so
people who like it will do it more and
it just amplifies and same with like sporting uh
skill or musical skill or whatever is this interaction
between an initial interest, maybe a talent. And the
reinforcement that a that a child can get by
being good at something and then wanting to practice
and so on. What that means is that you
can start out with um small differences between individuals
that through that experience get amplified. So nurture is
now amplifying um these initial differences that you see
between individuals and that kind of dynamic. You can
see, you know, in, in humans, but you can
see that in animals as well, actually, people have
studied that in, you know, in, in mice or
fish where small differences at, at birth lead to
this, you get this magnification across time and I,
I guess the, just the final aspect of that
that I find really interesting is that that. It's
not just an individual thing. It's, it's like uh
there's a almost a competitive process there where it's
like there's some niches for somebody to fill, um,
and if I'm filling them, there's no space for
anybody else to be that type of person, you
know, um. That was a little, uh, a loose
way of saying that, but the idea is that
there's the actual behaviors of any individual depends on
the behaviors of everybody else in the group, right?
It's a very interactive relational sort of thing, and
those dynamics emerge over time in a way that's
informed by initial differences, but that can actually amplify
or crystallize them.
You know, I, I'm, I'm always uh fascinated by
these topics surrounding whether in a particular case, someone
has been influenced by another person or by their
environmental circumstances or where those circumstances or that person
is just reinforcing underlying traits because I mean just
thinking about myself when I was Very small, I
mean, I was, I don't know, 566 years old.
I mean, my mother always stimulated me to read,
but I, but I mean I, I went beyond
that because I mean, my mother is a is
a teacher and her goal was like, oh, you
have to read to be a straight A student,
but I'm like, oh no, I don't care about
being a straight A student. I, I want to
read just because I want to learn new things.
I mean, the straight A student for me is
just a byproduct of that or something, and then,
and then I was like 5 or 6 and
also watching her entire collection of VHS tapes with
old movies. I mean, I was 5 years old
and watching movies about the Roman Empire, which probably
I shouldn't have done, but anyway, but uh I
mean, just to say that, uh, it's like. In
that particular case, of course, probably if my mother
didn't have the books and the tapes at home,
I mean I probably wouldn't have developed those habits
or wouldn't have been exposed to reading, watching movies
and so on, but at the same time it
er she stimulate. ME, but it was not like,
uh, oh my God, this is so boring. I'm
going to read like 5 minutes just for my
mother to leave me alone, but then I'm going
to drop the book and go play football or
something like that. No, I actually went beyond what
she wanted me to do because I really liked
learning from a. Very early age, so I mean,
was it really my mother influencing me or was
she just reinforcing it or was more of a
sort of, oh yeah, I have this environment at
my disposal, but I'm going to actively seek those
kinds of activities, you know, that
I
sometimes
think about that. Yeah,
I think it's probably, you know, some combination of
all of those, but I think that, you know,
what's interesting. With that particular example is that, is
that you have the opportunity to do that, right?
Where, um, and that, and this is, this is
a key thing where you have kids who have
different interests and different abilities and their personality traits
align them more, more or less to certain activities
that just sort of suits their personality, right? Um,
AND then, you know, we talked about this idea
of this amplification and children seeking their own environments
and building their own experiences and, um, you know,
that's, That's like in an ideal situation almost, right?
That's a that's a luxury situation and it's a
luxury that a lot of kids don't have in
the world is they don't like, it's great for
you. You could go and read a book because
you didn't have to go work in the mines
or uh go to the sweatshop or go out
in the, you know, go out in the fields
and, and, and whatever, right? So, um. I think
that, you know, the idea that that individuals can
flourish under certain sort of circumstances where they have
the luxury of becoming themselves, right, in that exploring
those things um and following their interests because they
don't have all these other pressures on them. And
that's where, you know, if you look at broader
sociological factors and things like poverty and socioeconomic um
stresses and conditions and so on. Um, YOU know,
those are where you can see the effects of
those kinds of things is like not on very
particular things, it's just like, well, do kids in
general have the opportunity to um follow their interests
or is there just so much, there's just so
much outside pressures that they're not um able to
be, um, you know, sitting in a room and,
and, um, reading all these books or whatever, whatever
the case may be.
Yeah. So, let's talk a little bit about the
group differences because I think that it's very important
here also, I, I mean, I, I won't, I
won't say this is a limitation of behavioral genetics.
I think that it's just a misconception that people
have about what uh uh what information they can
take from behavioral genetics studies because I've talked with
behavioral geneticists and all of them told. Me that
uh no behavioral genetics is not doesn't have proper
tools to study group differences. I mean if people
uh pick information from behavioral genetics to uh make
claims about I don't know, race differences, uh sex
differences, ethnicity differences, whatever, uh they're using it wrong
so uh but but but I I I mean
but do you think that. There's uh anything at
all apart from simply we uh uh knowing from
behavioral genetics that there's at least some genetic basis
to uh people's psychological traits. Is there anything there
that you think can be reasonably at all used
by people to make claims about group differences?
Well, I mean, let's, if we just think about
it in in principle, right? If we think about
the the the um the ancestry of any people
in the world. What that's going to reflect is
this very sort of, you know, a deep ancestry
of, of, um, migrations of, of humans, you know,
out of Africa, across um across Europe, across Asia,
into the Americas, into Oceania. Um, THE various populations
of hominins that they interacted with and interbred with,
migrations back into Africa, you know, it's really, really
complicated sorts of, of sets of, of interactions. And
then in more recent times, um, you know, you
had these Paleolithic, uh, people across, say, Europe, and
then they were largely replaced by migrations of Neolithic
farmers in, in the subsequent migrations with some interbreeding.
And then, You know, a few 1000 years later,
replaced again, or with some hybridizations from, you know,
invasions by steppe pastoralists and, and so on with
back migrations and all of which is the reason
I'm saying all of that is that, The idea
that you have this sort of clean branching of
different populations, which then just became the race, the
continental groups that we think of as classical races
that were defined by, you know, Linnaeus in the,
in the 70s, 100s as part of his classification
of, of different animals and species and so on.
Um. Those are just arbitrary groupings from a genetic
point of view, like there's much more tangled kind
of ancestry. It's not that they just diverged and
then didn't see each other for 10,000 years or
something like that. Um, THAT'S not the case. So
first of all, the, the groupings that people use
for the sort of classical races are arbitrary. It's
not that they don't reflect anything. It's just that
there's no reason to privilege that level because if
you look at like genetic. Markers, you can find
genetic markers that will distinguish, you know, as a
as a whole profile, people from Europe versus people
from Asia, for example. Um, BUT you'll also find
that that's those differences are continuously changing, right, as
you move for it's not like there's big monolithic
blocks where everybody in one group is the same
and everybody in the other group is the same,
and there's big differences between them. It's more of
a gradual kind of thing. And that reflects, you
know, ancient ancestry, but then of course, uh, each
of us has genetic variants that come from more
recent ancestry. I mean, any genetic variant in a
population arose as a mutation in somebody. Uh, SOME
of them arose thousands of years ago, and some
of them arose in just the sperm or egg
that generated you, right? I mean, that's the, that's
the continuum, right? Or some of them are just
brand new, and some of them are very ancient
and have spread through the population. And then there's
other ones like ones that arose a few generations
back. They're particular to one population versus another, but
really local population. So, you know, you can use,
you can use genetic profiling. To look at, you
know, you could find um distinctions between the profiles
of people from Portugal versus Ireland, and that's what
like 23andMe will tell you that information. But in
Ireland you could go more local, right? You can
find differences between people, you know, from Dublin versus
Cork, or, you know, even neighboring counties like in
England they had a whole map that all of
the little counties, so. All our any individual person's
genetic profile reflects this. Ancient vari variants that they
inherited, um, much more, you know, more recent ones
from, from, from local, um, populations and then very,
very recent ones that, um, arise. So all of
that is to say, But if you're thinking about
group differences, the first thing you have to think
about is like, how am I defining my groups?
And are they actually natural kinds, or am I
making some arbitrary cuts that I could, I could
cut it at a finer level if I wanted
to, right? So, once we say that, OK, that's
the sort of a, a background to the just
getting clear in our mind, what's the question that
we're asking. Then you can ask or say I've
got two populations, and within a population I find
that some trait is quite heritable, and within the
other population, it's also quite heritable. So there's some
variation in each of these, um, populations and a
lot of the variation is due to genetic differences.
And then say I find a difference in the
mean. Between those populations, it feels like a really
natural inference to say, well, I've shown that this
trait is genetic in these populations, there's a difference
between them, that must be genetic too, right? And
that's the fallacy that people um that people make.
And if you look at something like body mass
index, right, within any population, body mass index is
really highly heritable. And I mean even surprisingly if
you look at like adoptive siblings. They're not at
all correlated in body mass index, right? You would
think that growing up in the same family, you'd
have the same diet, you'd you'd have the same
tendencies, and there's just no correlation in body mass
index between adoptive siblings. So clearly there's big genetic
influences, right? But at the same time, Between countries,
there's massive differences in mean body mass index. And
those are environmental and cultural, right? They're due to
um lifestyle differences, social differences, and so on. The
like nobody looks at those and thinks, oh then
those must be genetic because we know, right? It's
obvious that they're um cultural and there's good evidence
that that's the case. When So when people look
at something like intelligence, where of course this has
been done, right, these claims have been made, um,
my first inclination is to say, well, look, the
actual performance on IQ tests is a product of
underlying biological ability, but also all of the opportunities
that people have had, all of the schooling, um,
you know, availability of education. But also, you know,
social factors that are pressures that, that contribute to
whether people actually have the luxury of, of engaging
in education. And, and then there's other factors like
infant nutrition and maternal nutrition and, and so on.
So, there's a whole load of social factors that
we know, um, within any, within any country contribute
to those kinds of, um, Scores, right? And, and
so we know that those things vary between countries
and even between subpopulations or socioeconomic, um, sort of
divisions within countries. So, um, you know, hypothetically speaking,
It could be, that could be due to genetic
differences. There's just no evidence that it actually is
due to genetic differences. Um, AND especially when we
know that cultural factors can have such a big
influence on it, it seems like that's the more
parsimonious explanation.
Yeah, no, uh, and I think that, uh, I
mean, it's very important to, to keep in mind
that, uh, I, I mean, of course these kinds
of conversations, um, at least in the minds of
certain people very quickly, um, get into a very
nasty political things like racism and eugenics and white
supremacy. And so on, because it, it really bothers
me quite a bit and not only, I mean,
even if we put just the political and moral
aspect of it aside for a second, even from
a scientific perspective, why is it that certain people
are so insistent in claiming that because supposedly in
the US you find an average of one standard
deviation difference in terms of average IQ between black
people and white people, why they make the claim
that that must be genetic. I mean there's no
evidence, there's no solid evidence of that and even
more so if you take into account the fact,
uh, like socioeconomic factors. That distinguish uh black people,
uh, the majority of black people from the majority
of white people and so on and so forth.
And then, for example, uh, when I hear claims
like, uh, oh, black people are more predisposed to
developing sickle cell anemia to protect them from malaria.
I, I mean that's also. Actually not true. It's
very specific populations in Africa or descendants of very
specific populations in Africa. I can't remember exactly that's
in sub-Saharan the location, yes, sub-Saharan Africa that actually
might have a predisposition to developing sickle cell anemia.
So I, I mean when people talk about. Uh,
BLACK people, white people, East Asian people, it seems
to be like a, seems to me like a
very crude scientific analysis
of. No, absolutely, so there's, there's just multiple sort
of, um, issues all tied up there, right? So
the first is that just these racial groups, these
classifications that we use, um, are just really, really
arbitrary and crude, and the idea that you would
say as a class. White Europeans are just this
monolithic group, and they're all the same, uh, for
the purposes of, you know, what we're interested in,
and they're all like this big differences with this
other group, and they're all the same. It's just
a nonsense, right? And that's what I was talking
about earlier, when there's like, you can just go
down the, the, the, the resolution of genetic differences
and profiles between people and groups of people, and
you'll just keep finding differences, right? I mean, in
any one of us, you can do 23andMe. Genetic
profile and get it to tell you which major
ancestry groups you're related to, but you can also
do a paternity test with it. I mean, it's
right, that's how fine it is, right? So, um,
so there's that, uh, and then, yeah, there's also
just sort of ignoring socioeconomic conditions where, you know,
it doesn't have to be like in the, in
the US those socioeconomic conditions because of the history
of the country. ARE often correlated with race, right?
In other countries, they're not correlated with race, right?
They, in Ireland, they're not correlated with race, um,
because we haven't had that kind of history, but
we still have socioeconomic divisions between areas that are
more or less socially well off. Um, AND you
see differences in, in terms of school performance and
how many students go to college and all of
those kinds of Um, all of those kinds of
measures that are readily explained by, um, access to
education and, um, and other sort of social factors
that influence, you know, whether people are just more
inclined to go get a job or whatever, right?
So, yeah, and I think, you know, when you're
asking why do people make these claims. Um, I
think it's a very obvious answer to why people
are inclined to make those claims is because they
fit with the view that they already have in
their mind, which is a view of racial differences
that, and not just of differences, but of, of,
uh, some being better than others, right, of superiority,
and then they can, they can look to some
scientific, um, Results or findings that they think support
that view, and so there's a sort of a
motivated reasoning and a kind of a confirmation bias,
but also just a misunderstanding of what those results
actually mean and what they don't mean. But it's
very, it's very challenging, you know, as a geneticist
to Uh, talk publicly about this stuff and, and
try and make sure that it's not misunderstood, um,
and that people aren't getting the wrong end of
the, of, of the stick, and, you know, because
the, the problem is, like as we've been discussing
all of this stuff through our whole conversation, it's
like, it's nuanced, it's contextual, it's interactive, it's not,
and those are hard stories to tell. Um, IT'S
much easier to say, no, it's all due to
this one thing or that one thing. Um, AND
so that's the challenge is to, is to try
and um. Talk about these things in a way
where you're getting conveying some of the complexities without
obviously, you know, overwhelming. People with them. Um, YEAH,
but avoiding or actually I think anticipating or preempting
the, the misunderstandings that can come.
Yeah. So, let me talk about another, uh, let's
talk about another factor here that might play a
role in, uh, development and psychology. Uh, WHERE do
you think we should place randomness in relation to
nature and nurture? I mean, do you think that
We should consider it to be part of either
nature or nurture or should it be thought of
as a as a third factor in, in the,
in development and psychology. Yeah,
so this is, um, as you know, one of
my favorite, um, topics to think about and, and,
and yes, I do think it is a third
factor. So when we think about. You know, I
talked about earlier, we'd say some trait is 70%
heritable, and, and you would say, OK, 70% is
due to genes, that means genetic variation, then the
other 30% must be environment, and people just have
that kind of dichotomy. It's like either genes or
environment and so there's a, a, a, a sort
of an easy inference that the limits of heritability
that behavioral genetics has shown is actually proof that
environmental factors are affecting these things like say personality
traits. And by environmental, I mean, in the typical
understanding of that word, which is something exogenous, something
outside the organism itself, right? That's a normal colloquial
understanding of the word. It, it unfortunately, there's a
statistical um definition of what's called the non-shared environment,
which is like not family environment, but anything else.
So you can kind of partition. Effects of, of
shared genes, of a shared family, and then you've
got something left over, and that's called the non-shared
environment, which again makes it sound like it must
be something outside the organism, but it isn't necessarily.
It could be something endogenous inside the organism. And
really this just it it it comes from the
idea that the genome is not a blueprint for
an organism. It doesn't encode everything about the final
product. It really encodes kind of the settings of
rules for development, and, but it encodes them rather
loosely, right? Because it can't control once it starts
making some proteins of different levels and different different
cells. Those proteins are just going to jitter around
in the cell, they're going to diffuse around and
bounce into each other and bounce off and and
and like at the molecular level, it's incredibly noisy.
So the genome that can't control that. All it
can do is say, OK, I'm going to make
this much of protein A and this much of
protein B and this much of protein C, and
let the self-organizing dynamics of these cells make a
limb and let these ones make a heart or
a brain or whatever it is, right? So, um,
when we look at the developmental outcome from clones,
right, in animals. Um, WE see loads of variation
between individual clones. We see that in the, in,
in the anatomy, we see it in neuroanatomy, we
see it in the connections of individual cells, even
with it like down to the level of individual
neurons in the fly nerve cord, for example, which
is, you know, what I worked on as a
PhD student. Those individual neurons that you can look
from segment to segment, they have names, right? And
you could say, here's the RP3 neuron, and it
innervates this muscle here, and it does it 100%
of the time in a wild type animal and
I can see it from segment to segment, but
in a, you know, if you start adding genetic
variation. Maybe it only does it 70% of the
time, but that's really probabilistic. There's nothing from outside
the system that is determining that because on two
sides of the embryo or from one segment to
another, it either makes the connection or it doesn't.
So there's genuinely probabilistic stuff that happens during neural
development. That can influence um the way that your
brain is wired, literally, right? And if you look
at the brains of monozygotic twins from like as
as soon as you can image their brains, they're
already different from each other. Of course, they're much,
much more similar than any non-related people, but there's
still a lot of, of, um, variation left over.
And, you know, what's interesting in neural development in
particular is that you could say, OK, maybe, you
know, I've made a, I, I've made a few
more neurons here than, than, than there, uh, or
then in my, in my imaginary twin, um, I
have a few more axons going from this region
to that region, whatever. It's kind of like quantitative
differences. But you can also get qualitative differences, and
the reason is that neural development is a series
of, of contingent events where for each event to
happen properly or, you know, I, I shouldn't say
properly, but along the typical um way. The previous
events have to also have happened. And so you
can get noise that happens at one time during
development that then has cascading effects over the subsequent
trajectories of development. And to me that can explain
things like um like the inheritance of handedness. So
handedness is like say on average 10% of the
population is left-handed. If you have, uh, you know,
both of your parents are left-handed, your, your chance
of being left-handed is about 25%. If your identical
twin is left-handed, it's also about 25%. But it's
still just probabilistic, right? If you cloned someone left-handed.
And you made 100 clones, 25 of them might
be left-handed and 75 might be right-handed. So, um,
And the idea is that like at some point
during development, there's some sort of noisy thing and
then development gets channeled down one trajectory or another,
which are in a sense competing in that in
that example. So, um, yeah, for me, developmental variation,
this endogenous variation, which, like you said, it's just
based on the randomness, the stochastic nature of the
molecular processes that are actually going on in the
developing brain plus. These potential cascading contingencies um is
a major source of differences in how our brains
get wired that can be expressed in behavioral tendencies.
So I have one last question then. uh, I,
I want to ask you this because since you
also wrote an entire book on uh the biology
and the neuroscience of free will, I want to
hear your thoughts about this. So, um, I mean.
Do you think that uh perhaps this sort of,
of, of course it might be also because it
is very relevant, it's just part of uh the
uh the culture surrounding the scientific community and all
of that, but do you think that perhaps There's
also a tendency of uh behavioral scientists to endorse
determinism because in a way that would make uh
their predictions or their ability to predict behavior uh
stronger. I mean, because I mean if we just
try to eliminate these, I mean, messy things and
uh. Othersome things related to free will and things
we cannot really predict, we cannot really account for
in our models, then, I mean, this study or
that study that I did, uh, whether it's, whether
we're talking about genetic factors, environmental factors, then, uh,
I mean, it has more, it, it is more
authoritative, let's say if I Say that, oh I
can predict with 50% probability that someone will do
this in these kinds of circumstances or someone will
have these personality traits if they have these genes
and so on and so forth. I mean, do,
do, uh, do you think that there's, uh, uh,
that sort of a tendency among, uh,
I'm not sure, um, I'm not sure whether. I
would sort of identify with that motivation to be
um claiming more predictive power than than you should,
maybe that's true for some for some people. I
think more generally there's an intuition at play here
where um you know I this this came to
me when I was watching my son play a
video game where he was interacting with this non-player
character. And he said something to it, and it
had certain responses and it's certain actions and so
on, and I was thinking, well, OK, it's like
he's doing something and playing that game, but the
non-player character is not doing anything because they're just
playing out their programming, but they've been programmed to
act in certain ways and they're just playing that
out, and I think the. The, the intuition that
you're talking about comes from thinking, well, shit, maybe
we're like that. Like, maybe I've been preprogrammed, uh,
you know, first by evolution because we we're all
humans and, and, uh, you know, we've spent the,
the conversation here talking about differences, but The similarities,
you know, are, are huge, right? Everything that makes
us human and different from other animals, um, so
that human nature is there and we can't change
that. And then we have our individual nature it's
like, well, I didn't choose to have these genes
that made me more extroverted or more neurotic or
whatever. Um, SO there's this sense like I can't
change that and now that's affecting my behavior. So
am I really in control? Do I really have
free will or am I just playing out my
programming? And I think it's a, it, it's like
it's not an unreasonable intuition, but it's wrong in
the sense that uh it gives too much weight
to these predispositions in like as if they determine
your behavior on a moment to moment basis. And
they don't, right? What determines your behavior on a
moment to moment basis is this lifelong trajectory that
we talked about earlier of how you have come
to be the person that you are with the
knowledge that you have, with the beliefs, with the,
um, with the habits and policies that you have,
with the commitments that you made, with the ongoing
projects, with all of your, the relationships that you
have with everyone and all of your memories. As
well as these underlying biological predispositions which are in
play, but they're like a minor, they're not trivial
because they've affected. The trajectory of your life, right?
But they haven't governed it directly in a deterministic
fashion. And so, you know, once you think that
At any moment you have some agency because, uh,
basically evolution can't pre-wire in the right thing to
do in every situation. For certain organisms, they, they
get around in a, uh, their, their world is
not that complex, and they don't have to be
very flexible because they're only responding to a few
different things in the world, right? And their evolution
can kind of wire in some fixed control policies.
That allow the organism to adapt to the conditions,
the small range of conditions it encounters. But the
whole point of having a nervous system is that
you can adapt to all kinds of new stuff,
right? Because evolution can't say, give you just a
lookup table for every possible scenario you're going to
encounter. Instead, it hit upon the idea of like,
why am I doing all the work? Let me
give these things of their own onboard learning system
and let them figure it out themselves, right? So
when you encounter a new scenario. Well then you're
gonna take in the information, assess it with respect
to what you know about the world, with your
current states, your motivations, what are your goals, um,
any other pressures and information, and then decide what
to do, and that's a genuine deciding. It's not,
it's not just, uh, looking up some algorithmic thing
that already pre pre-exists. It's really open, right? There's
bunch, you could do a bunch of things and
you're going to try and figure out what to
do and at every moment of your life. Exercising
that agency contributes to you becoming the person that
you are right now, right? So, yeah, so my
view is that there's, there's nothing in the statement
that we're not blank slates. That undermines free will,
right, in the sense that my free will. And
in fact, Ricardo, this is exactly why I wrote
Free Agents is because I had written innate and
some, and, and some people were taking that to
my mind the wrong way, like as if we're,
we're just robots, and I wanted to actually explore
the idea that no, we, we, we do have
predispositions, but they underpin our agency. They don't undermine
our agency. And, you know, in one way you
could say, The ability for you to act freely
is to act like you, right? I mean, that's,
you don't want to freedom is not the, the,
uh, you know, ability to do just anything. That's
not, that's not a freedom, that's just randomness, right?
What you want as an autonomous agent for you
if you think of freedom reflecting autonomy and your,
your ability to control things is that you can
express yourself, right? You can express your identity, you
can do you. You can be Ricardo, right? Um,
AND you can continue to do that through time,
and that's what it means to be a self,
right, is to have that continuity and integrity where,
um, you're bringing your identity and your character and
your knowledge to the world and continuing to act
like yourself, right? Um, AND so I don't see
anything in that. That undermines the idea that that
we're acting freely. Unless you start with a weird
conception of freedom, which is effectively like freedom from
any prior cause whatsoever, which is just kind of
nonsensical. It just doesn't make any sense. You just
be random, right? I don't want to be free
from any prior causes. I want to be a
cause of things in the world and I think
that I can be.
Well, uh, let me just tell you before we
go that, uh, I should warn you to not
use the word non-playable character too much or NPC
because, er, without even noticing you might start also
using main character and then you might get into
a rabbit hole on the. Internet and you might
become a conspiracy theorist and thinking that everyone out
there is an NPC and the main character so
or at the very least people might confuse you
with uh Gen Z so they might think you're
Gen Z so
we had, we had NPCs before the Gen Zs
came along. Yeah.
OK, great. So, uh, look, I, I'm going to
leave again a link to your latest book Free
Agents in the description. Apart from that, where can
people find you and your work on the internet?
Yeah, so I have a, a website. It's, um,
KJ Mitchell.com, and I'm on Blue Sky these days
at, at wiring therain, um, I guess it's tbsky.social.
Um, YEAH, so, generally there and, um. Uh, AND
on the dissenter, generally, so.
Well, maybe next year you'll be back. Let's see.
Yeah, great. Thanks a million.
Yeah, thank you. Hi guys, thank you for watching
this interview until the end. If you liked it,
please share it, leave a like and hit the
subscription button. The show is brought to you by
Enlights Learning and Development done differently. Check their website
at enlights.com and also please consider supporting the show
on Patreon or PayPal. I would also like to
give a huge thank you to my main patrons
and PayPal supporters, Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo,
Bernard Seyaz Olaf, Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud
Wolff, Tim Hollis, Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst
Connolly. Then Dmitri Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs,
Colin Holbrookfield, Governor, Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti
Agnun, Svergoo, and Hal Herzognun, Machael Jonathan Labran, John
Yardston, and Samuel Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware,
Tom Hammel, Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain
Roach, Diego Londono Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis
Nicole Barbaro, Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G.
Alman, Semov, Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian
Price, Edward Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti,
Gabriel Pancortezus Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony
Smith, John Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg
Jarno, Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin,
David Williams, Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D.
Lee Jr. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber,
Robert Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly
Johnson, Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson,
Ismael Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate
Van Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali
Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David
Pinsov, Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A
special thanks to my producers is are Webb, Jim
Frank Lucas Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict
Mueller, Thomas Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon
Negro, Al Nick Cortiz and Nick Golden, and to
my executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis,
and Rosie. Thank you for all.